what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to a video
titled 10 major red flags and in women
this is by
courtney ryan before i begin do not
forget to subscribe to the channel as
you guys know i'm trying to get to 20
000 subscribers by the end of the
well june basically that's my goal
um okay let me go
sorry sometimes i forget to like breathe
when i'm talk doing my intro
okay hello and welcome back to my
channel i just want to see if i agree
with these
courtney ryan and in today's video think
of this as
the crystal ball into the brain of a
woman and
red flags you should be looking for in
your relationship
so these are 10 red flags that you're
going to want to pay attention to
when you're dating a girl so everyone
has their own personal relationship red
flags
everyone has their own deal breakers but
these are going to be 10
pretty intense red flags that you should
be paying attention to
i want to help you guys i am on your
side as a woman i feel like i have a
pretty good
idea of when women do this i have a ton
of friends that do some of these things
i had people in my sorority that did
these things i've been around a lot of
women my entire life so
trust me i've heard it all and the
reason why i think it's so important for
all of you guys out there in
relationships even not in relationships
and just looking for a girlfriend in
general
to be listening to a list like this is
because a lot of times when we're in
relationships we put our blinders up
we want things to work out we don't want
our relationship to fail we don't want
to be sad
i've been there i've done it and i have
ignored about a million and a half
red flags that have been waving in front
of my face because
of just simply not wanting something to
fail not wanting something to not work
out so
trust me it's important to pay attention
to these things because most of these
are patterns and behaviors that become
even more intense later down the road
and you'll be questioning yourself and
wondering why the heck you stayed in
this relationship so
let's jump into the video okay one flag
is she's possessive and needy and by
this i mean for example
you tell her that you're going to hang
out with your friends for the weekend
and she gets mad at you because you're
hanging out with someone besides her
it's okay to want to hear someone and
hang out with someone a lot but when she
cannot physically function without being
with you
or she gets mad when you're with someone
else it could be anyone else not even a
girl just anyone else besides her
this is a sign of possessiveness and
control
this does not get better as the
relationship progresses in fact it
probably just will get worse
number two how do they treat people when
you go out to dinner how do they treat
the waitress
when you go grab a coffee how do they
treat the barista how does she
this is good advice really with anybody
because
how someone treats people is very
important
all of these are big red flags if she's
treating them poorly
if she's being rude if she's acting like
she's better than them
she could be the most beautiful or hot
or whatever
girl in the world and if she has an ugly
personality
yeah look straight how she is treating
these people
is probably how she's going to treat you
later on down the road when you do
something that
dissatisfies her or isn't up to par with
her standards
yeah i think how people treat people
when they're mad is especially important
keep that in mind too number three we
have
excessive jealousy so a little bit of
jealousy is healthy i think it's totally
normal
for someone to be a little bit jealous
every now and then but when it's
excessive
it becomes a problem for example say
something funny happened at work
and you tell your girlfriend about it
and the story just so happens to involve
a girl
the second you bring up the girl she
instantly is not interested in the story
she gets mad at you
she accuses you of x x and x whatever it
is
if she's getting mad for no reason and
you haven't given her a reason to be mad
over a girl this is an issue
what do you think is the definition let
me know in the comments what you think
the definition of excessive jealousy is
because i've i've seen both sides right
i've seen guys
like tell girls they're being excessive
and being crazy when they're really not
being crazy like the guy is just doing
shady stuff but i've also seen girls act
nuts
and like to me personally if you're
married or in a long-term committed
relationship
i don't think you should be hanging out
like one-on-one with another
gender like i think like a group trip
totally fine but like one-on-one
off the table um but yeah let me know in
the comments what you think is like
excessive this signifies that she's
insecure she's gonna be constantly
paranoid it's going to be very unhealthy
for the both of you so you're better off
just
getting out of it like i said a little
bit of jealousy is totally okay
i have been jealous before i think
jealousy is something that everyone has
felt at some point in their life
but there's a very big difference
between a little bit of jealousy to keep
the relationship interesting
and excessive jealousy number four she
doesn't
say thank you so think about if you've
taken her out on a few dates
you've paid for all of her stuff and she
did not even say thank you
if she's not appreciative of these
little things that you're doing for her
she's never really going to be
appreciative of
things either and this can create a lot
of resentment in a relationship
especially if you feel like you're the
one that's always giving always paying
and she's giving you nothing in return
it's one thing if she forgets to say it
once or twice but if you're noticing a
pattern where
she has kind of a princess mentality and
just expects it and never says thank you
run for the hills number five we have no
goals
or hobbies so for example say you ask
her where she pictures herself five
years from now
and she can't even formulate a thought
she can't even tell you where she begins
to see herself
in a year two years three years four
years at all if she is unable to talk
about her future
you ask her what her hobbies are and she
says she doesn't have any
shopping by the way is not a hobby i
like shopping
but it's not a hobby this is an issue
because you want to be with someone that
has
ambition you want to be with someone
that has goals and aspirations and
things that they want to accomplish in
life
and you don't want to be with a girl
that's an excessive spender
like i'm telling you if there's a if
you're dating someone
and she's okay with you spending more
than you can afford
in a month like on her that's not okay
and i'm not saying like i'm 100 i
believe in chivalry i think that men
should pay the majority of the time but
like
when i met my boyfriend right i found
out he was staying
at actually nevermind i'm not i'm not
gonna
tell personal stories because i don't
wanna put them out there like that but
um
like i'm just cheap and i think that
that's a really good trait to have
not even just as a girl like in people
because
if you're spending too much money you're
not building the generational wealth
that you want to build
okay especially if you're someone that
has all of these things
it's impossible to be with someone that
doesn't share these same interests as
you
so keep that in mind as well how are you
supposed to be a power couple and build
each other up if she can't even build
herself up
or has any kind of goal for herself
number six we have
unrealistic communication expectations
and i'm not talking about you've ghosted
her for a week and she's upset with you
that is totally acceptable and she has
every reason to be upset with you if
that is the case
i'm talking about example you're at work
and you haven't texted her back all day
because
you're at work and she's freaking out
blowing up at you getting mad at you for
not texting her back
this is a huge red flag
because she is expecting you to drop
everything in your life for her
to make you her entire world and this is
just
an unrealistic expectation and the crazy
thing is if guys
are then not successful because they
spend too much time like with the girl
then the girl
ends up getting mad later because he
doesn't have money and at any point in a
relationship but if you're saying this
in the beginning this is going to be a
huge problem that continues throughout
your entire relationship so please keep
this in mind or you're out with your
friends and she's expecting you to text
her every five seconds
you are allowed to have a life outside
of your partner
i would argue that this is one of the
most important things
when you're in a relationship it's okay
to enjoy doing things together it's okay
to want to be with a person and spend
time with a person
but it's so incredibly important to have
a life and
interests and goals and hobbies and
spend time
apart and not spend every waking moment
together doing every single thing
together
being your own person and bringing your
individuality into a relationship
is what makes a relationship work number
seven she brings
up past relationships too much so
it's okay in the beginning of your
relationship to ask each other about
past relationships and maybe why
something didn't work out
i think it's totally okay to be a little
bit curious about this and to wonder
this about the person that you're
getting to know
and you're with however if she's
constantly bringing up her ex
unsolicited with no context this is an
issue
she's probably not over him if she keeps
talking about him all the time
that's kind of weird and if she's
constantly bringing up your ex
and asking you questions and getting mad
at you about things that you maybe did
with her or people that you've slept
with this is a huge issue it's a control
thing
and it's a lack of control over what
you've done in the past or who you've
been with
and it's going to be something that
carries on for your whole relationship
there's going to be 90 years old in a
nursing home and she's still going to be
bringing up your ex so
if you don't want that to be you don't
even put up with this kind of girl
number eight she just got out of a
relationship
so this doesn't sound like it would be
that bad i know sometimes things happen
you run into her at the train station
and it's magical like a movie
sometimes things like that they just
work out and it makes sense but if she
just got out of a relationship and you
meet her on tinder or
at a bar and she's already seeking out
another relationship
this signifies that she can't be alone
she's insecure with herself
she's not independent she feels like she
needs someone with her to be happy
this is a problem because like i
mentioned earlier it's so important to
be your own person and to bring your
individuality into a relationship
in order for it to work and the biggest
red flag here is that you're a rebound
nobody wants to be a rebound it just is
what it is yeah you don't want to be
that guy and you're going to be
questioning it your whole entire
relationship
number nine she has no girlfriends
this doesn't also sound like it would be
that bad but this signifies that
she doesn't have any committed
relationship she doesn't have any
constant relationships in her life and i
think this is really important just to
show that
you can keep relationships for a long
time you aren't just going through
friends like hotcakes so when a girl
yeah and that's a really important thing
to see and especially like men and women
to see
can they maintain friendships even just
friendships for a long period of time
because if all your friends
don't like you and talk [ __ ] about them
you have to
ask yourself why girl says she doesn't
have any girlfriends
this just shows that she can't maintain
relationships and you have to wonder
why the friendships didn't work out it's
kind of like yeah yeah
that has dated a million guys i want to
be friends with this girl
she seems cool as hell constantly talks
bad about all of them and says
you know they were just jerks it didn't
work out but why because you were
the common denominator right also right
and that's
that's really important to be with a
girl that takes accountability
and makes changes like based on
what's happened in the past really
important to
have friends outside of your
relationship as well so if you're with a
girl
and she wants to spend all her time with
you she doesn't have any friends
no girlfriends no guy friends just no
friends in general
this is an issue because it's so
incredibly important
to have other relationships outside of
your
romantic relationship that you're in and
lastly number 10
she has cheated this i think is the most
obvious one
yeah once a cheater always a cheater i
am a firm believer in this from people
that i have dated
in my past once they cheat once they
just keep cheating because they know
they can get away with it but the
biggest one here that i think a lot of
people ignore
is did she cheat with you was she dating
a guy
did she cheat on him with you and now
he's in a relationship with you
well you might think well you know it
just didn't work out for them it's great
with us
what happens when she gets bored what
happens when she no longer wants to be
with you or she meets someone that she
thinks is better than you
she's gonna do the same exact thing to
you that she did to the last guy
with you if anything the fact that she's
cheated before just shows
a lack of commitment a lack of respect
and a lack of loyalty which
why would you want to date a girl like
that guys just being 100 honest
like i said i'm on your side i believe
in you
if she cheats she belongs in the streets
kick her out get rid of her you're
better than that all right guys that
concludes my list of tennis i
liked her okay this is the man of sphere
will always say that you can't take
dating advice from women and that's why
i'm actually not super quick to give
like dating advice
because in my opinion like the
manosphere won't take me seriously
anyway
um but like those are all very
level-headed and like good
ideas for relationships so let me know
in the comments what do you think the
biggest
red flags are in women and let me know
what you guys think don't forget to
subscribe
please